today on the matt walsh show after a
series of memorial services across
several states john lewis was laid to
rest at a
funeral attended by many people
including 50 congressmen
uh and and many others today we'll
discuss the blatant
and outrageous double standard that
allows departed politicians
and other people to have multiple
funerals while
average americans still aren't even
allowed to have one also
five headlines including a whole trove
of epstein documents have been released
a number of uh very famous names are
mentioned we'll discuss that in our
daily cancellation
i will finally cancel the most evil
deranged
and dangerous psychopaths in the country
these are these are people begging for a
cancellation and they'll finally get it
today
all of that is on the way but first the
show today is brought to you by vincero
watches
um you know there are many occasions
where you may need a watch
you know when a watch is gonna be
something that ties the whole outfit
together and
kind of gives you that extra pop that
you're looking for uh whether you're
going for a night out you're going to a
wedding
you got a business meeting you know
whatever whatever it is that's why you
need vincero watches
a watch should be something you look
forward to putting on every day and
that's exactly how i feel about my
vincero watches vincero is uh dedicated
to the craft
uh they they put the time and effort
into crafting these timepieces and you
could tell
you really tell when you wear them that
um that there's been a lot of
time put into them and a lot of care uh
these are not just like
factory assembled cookie cutter watches
these are uh
watches that a lot of effort and time
have been put into with vegero there's
no brand name markup no big time price
tags
um their promise to you is simple solid
well-made products that you will enjoy
wearing
during this time they continue to do
right by their buyers as well these guys
they know just how important it is to
shop
from brands that you trust so go check
out their watches at vincerowatches.com
wall so you get access to
our exclusive discount as well vincero
offers free shipping
30 day returns and they guarantee your
watch for two years and this is why they
have over 22 000
5 star reviews don't trust me trust what
the people are saying about ventura
watches
if you visit venturawatches.com walsh
and when you purchase the discount walsh
is automatically applied at checkout so
it's that easy to shop that's how you
get the discount
that's just make sure to put at
venturawatches.com
walsh like i said these are timepieces
that you're going to enjoy wearing every
single day
um and if you don't vicero will make it
right that's their promise to you if you
don't like it
they're going to make it right if you
don't love it they're going to take care
of it but
you will love it i guarantee you that go
shop vincero uh the deal is really too
good to pass up go to v-i-n-c-e-r-o
watches dot com forward slash walls do
not pay full price
on these beautiful timepieces take
advantage of our exclusive discount
and get up to 20 off for your entire
order
okay representative john lewis laid to
rest at a funeral in georgia on thursday
the funeral attended by dignitaries
former presidents politicians uh from
all over the country including 50
members of congress were there
it was a culmination of several days
worth of memorials and public
remembrances for the late congressman
and civil rights icon uh the journey
began with a service
in an alabama chapel and then another at
troy university in fact there were a
couple at
troy university i believe um the
congressman's body was also
ceremonially escorted across a a bridge
in selma by a military honor guard it
was a
horse-drawn carriage there was an
audience there watching that
lewis was then laid in state in dc for a
few days of public viewing
and then it was brought back down south
to atlanta for a series of memorials on
monday follow or
wednesday followed by the funeral on
thursday in all there were more than 10
ceremonies across
five different cities in
three different states
well two states in dc i guess the final
ceremony uh the funeral
was invite only but many of the pews if
you if you look at the
for instance this this screenshot here
you can see many of the pews were
still packed tightly with people sitting
shoulder to shoulder now under normal
circumstances
i would not begrudge a prominent figure
like john lewis his memorials and
posthumous celebrations
lewis you know obviously isn't the first
such figure to have
memorials like this john mccain died two
years ago and uh he had a similarly
packed schedule of memorial services
but the difference between two years ago
and today obviously
is the coronavirus and the accompanying
lockdowns and restrictions that we have
all been
under or at least most of us have been
under in most circumstances and that's
the point for months now
many americans have either been
prohibited from
holding funeral services at all for
their deceased loved ones
or have been forced to hold very small
gatherings attended only by immediate
family members
i know people who have been in this
situation all of us know people
or or you might be one of these people
um i've heard these stories i've gotten
many emails from people talking about
this
their father died a grandfather even a
child died
and either there was no funeral or
there was just a very small funeral
attended by immediate family members
the cdc the cdc labels large or
medium-sized
in-person funeral services as quote
highest risk
events and in many places such events
are still banned
there was a funeral director who wrote
an article for the washington post back
in april
and the article said that you know
saying goodbye to a loved one has become
a lonely affair
and that's true but not for everyone
a whole series of exceptions were made
for john lewis
just as they were made for george
floyd's various memorials and funerals
now
granted um
as i said under normal circumstances it
it it would it would make sense for john
lewis to have all these memorial
services
and uh under normal circumstances
there's nothing absurd about it
under any circumstance to have all these
memorial services for george floyd and
the golden casket and everything
even without coronavirus would be
totally absurd
um but even so you know when it comes to
chronovirus exceptions made in both
cases
and the exceptions don't just apply to
the events themselves buck sexton makes
a good point he points out
on twitter dc regulations require that
travelers from georgia
must self-quarantine for 14 days well
will the the 50 congressmen
who attended lewis's funeral in atlanta
are they going to proceed directly to
self-quarantine for 14 days
somehow i doubt it and
this has always been the problem
with the coronavirus policies and
restrictions
it's not just that they represent
unconstitutional infringements on our
liberties
though they do but that they are
blatantly arbitrary and this is one of
the reasons why
they represent unconstitutional
infringements on our liberty
in many cases like with the you know you
know
you've got you've got more restrictions
on
church attendance in some places you
can't go to church at all
but you can still go to a blm protest
not only is that arbitrary but because
it is arbitrary that's one of the
reasons why it's an unconstitutional
infringement because this is viewpoint
discrimination
it's the government saying well you know
if you have this point of view and if
you're gathering for this reason then
it's okay but not for this over here
now why can john lewis have a dozen
memorials in five cities while you
weren't allowed to have even one for
your beloved grandmother who died
the answer is quite simply that your
grandmother's life was not as important
as the life of john lewis according to
the people in power
that's what they're telling you that is
really the reason that there can't be
any other reason
no right now nobody else would be
allowed to do this you wouldn't be
allowed to have
uh you know for most people who died it
wouldn't be an option anyway to have
multiple memorial services but
the point is you you wouldn't be allowed
to you just simply couldn't do it
almost anywhere in the country you could
do it for john lewis because
the powers that be say he's more
important than the rest of you peons
simple as that you know why can't you go
to church
even while thousands of black lives
matter demonstrators and writers can
gather together crammed together in the
street
because the powers that be don't care
about your church
or or or believe in its message they do
care about blm and they do believe in
its message
so one is allowed but not the other this
is
the true outrage and disgrace here
and the word outrage is so overused that
i'm hesitant to use it but
but there are some things that are
actual outrages this is one of them
and if you had you know if you lost a
loved one in the last few
months then yes i think actual real
outrage is probably what you're feeling
when you see this
this is perhaps the most explicit case
of rules for thee but not for me that we
have seen in modern times
it is the very definition of tyranny
now that's one notable thing to discuss
uh from the funeral yesterday the other
is obama speaking of disgraceful obama
and his disgraceful political stump
speech that he delivered
during his eulogy was supposed to be a
eulogy of john lewis here's
one piece of that naming it the john
lewis voting rights act
that is a fine tribute
but john wouldn't want us to stop there
just trying to get back to where we
already were
once we pass the john lewis voting
rights act
we should keep marching to make it even
better
by making sure every american is
automatically registered to vote
including former inmates who've earned
their second chance
by adding polling places and expanding
early voting
and making election day a national
holiday so
if you are somebody who's working in a
factory
or you're a single mom who's got to go
to her job
and doesn't get time off
[Applause]
you can still cast your ballot by
guaranteeing that every american citizen
has equal representation
in our government including the american
citizens who live in washington d.c
and in puerto rico they're americans
by ending some of the partisan
gerrymandering
so that all voters have the power to
choose their politicians not the other
way around
and if all this takes eliminating the
filibuster
another jim crow relic in order to
secure the god-given rights of every
american
then that's what we should do and of
course he also attacked trump's use of
federal law enforcement officers
but today we witness with our own eyes
police officers kneeling on the necks
of black americans
george wallace may be gone
but we can witness
our federal government sending agents to
use tear gas and batons
against peaceful demonstrators
andy also started yammering about the
filibuster and uh basically went down a
whole list of political grievances
this is this this is just to remind you
uh
first of all this is a eulogy so let's
remember that it's what this is supposed
to be
you could kind of forget when you
watched that this is a huge it's
supposed to be a eulogy now of course
using a eulogy as a platform for your
political stump speech is tasteless and
grotesque to put it mildly
but it also shows you something
important i think about the left and how
the left operates because
for most normal people the eulogy is a
time
first to celebrate the life and
achievements of the deceased
and then also um in in most of the
funerals i've been to it is also it is a
place for spiritual
reflections for hopes and prayers for
the repose of the
of the of the departed soul right but
obama as a as a leftist
see he draws no real distinction between
personal political and spiritual
for him it's all the same he can't
separate those things they're
they're all exactly the same politics is
the religion of the left so stumping for
a voting rights act at a eulogy to a
leftist
that's okay it's a spiritual message and
that's why a lot of you know leftists on
social media
while others were complaining about this
a lot of leftists were saying what's the
problem i don't see the issue here
well i know you don't see the issue
you don't see the issue with someone
getting up at a eulogy
and start proposing bills that they want
to see
passed in congress it's not the place
for it but to you it is the place for it
because it's political
and this is a church and for you
politics religion spiritual
it's all the same politics is your
religion that's why you don't see the
issue with it
but nonetheless it's still disgraceful
all right let's move on to our five
headlines
[Music]
well as we're about to get into some
interesting news here here's something
um
the spacex capsule will be landing this
sunday august 2nd
the first time that spacex will have
completed a successful crude mission to
the international space station
the first time in over a decade that a
crude spaceship was launched from the
united states so in short it's a pretty
big deal
uh and we're going to be streaming it
across youtube facebook and
dailywire.com featuring a special
all all access live discussion with
daily wire god king jeremy boring
all access members can join the chat and
talk to jeremy during the live stream of
the mission
then you can stick around afterwards for
a live stream q a where you can watch
him answer
your questions in real time so don't
miss out join all access at
dailywire.com and get 20
off with code access that's
dailywire.com walsh 20 off
with code access number one the jizzlane
maxwell case i still don't know if
that's how you pronounce her name uh i'm
not sure if anyone knows how to
pronounce her name but i'm just going
with that hundreds of
pages of documents were unsealed last
night some of the documents are
transcripts from a deposition
um with virginia roberts the woman who
alleges that she was
trafficked uh one of many women
trafficked hundreds of women trafficked
by uh
maxwell and epstein and she was a minor
at the time
like so many other women were other
documents
uh like emails and other things are
included for example there's an email
between
epstein and maxwell where epstein
appears to be feeding maxwell a
statement that
she can give to the press denying
allegations against her
so stuff like that more interesting are
the names that roberts gives she says
that she was directed to have sex with
be abused by alan dershowitz
um former new mexico governor bill
richardson
a number of prominent businessmen and
financial guys and she named bill
clinton as a guy who was on epstein's
sex island
uh though she she says she never saw him
commit any crimes
but you know bill clinton clinton on sex
island i think we could
use our common sense on this one my
concern to be honest with you is that
this will be is it's it almost that it
will amount to zero consequences for
any of these scumbags um
one because there's no justice in the
world especially for rich and powerful
people we know that
and also too because there are so many
names and so much information
and so many documents that i guess i'd
be concerned
that it all sort of ends up getting
buried under the avalanche
and there's not any particular focus on
one of these guys or the other
i hope that doesn't happen but that's my
worry and in any case this is just the
tip of the iceberg there are many more
documents out there
and many big names by the way were
redacted on the documents that we saw so
we'll see what happens um the the names
that we really
need to see i think are the people who
are still currently wielding power
most of the names we've gotten are
former this or that
former politicians uh i want to see the
current ones too
number two st louis prosecutors will not
charge officer darren wilson in the
death of michael brown
that's the headline if it sounds like
i'm reading headlines from 2014 and i've
gotten confused or something and i went
back on google by accident
i'm not this is a headline from last
night st louis prosecutors
apparently reviewed darren wilson's case
at the request of michael brown's family
because this is what prosecutors do now
i guess they're
they work as personal attorneys for the
families of alleged victims
so they they asked him to review the
case and he did
and last night he announced the results
of the review um
that nobody knew was being conducted and
they say there isn't enough evidence to
charge darren wilson
we already knew that of course because
this is now the third investigation into
this shooting
third a grand jury investigated it the
department of justice under barack obama
investigated it
and now a st louis prosecutor has
investigated it
maybe we'll get a you know we'll just
we'll just get an investigation every
every few years like a
there's a ceremonial sort of thing
all of these investigations have found
that there is nothing to charge the
officer with
three investigations all come to the
same conclusion
and that's because michael brown was a
violent [ __ ] we can say this now
conclusively
we could have we could have said it six
years ago conclusively
michael brown was a violent criminal who
assaulted a store clerk for no reason
just assaulted him then assaulted a cop
and tried to disarm him
and and died in the process we know that
we know from witnesses we know it from
forensics we know it now from three
investigations what else do we need but
of course none of this matters
it can be investigated 10 more times and
the people who have bought into the
michael brown
false narrative will continue to buy
into it it doesn't matter what comes out
i mean
they could release video footage showing
what happened
um which is that we know what happened
michael brown charged darren wilson
and tried to take his weapon um
you know for a lot of forensics evidence
for example and ballistic evidence uh
for example
you know gun power powder residue on
michael brown which
you wouldn't get if wilson was yards
away
shooting brown while he has hands up
saying don't shoot
the gunpowder residue is because brown
was right on top of
darren wilson when the gun went off
anyway but it doesn't matter people that
have bought into the to the false
narrative will continue
to defend it number three the nba
started back up again last night
and uh every player coaching ref knelt
for the anthem
there you go there you can see the
spectacle uh now charles barkley
during the halftime show provoked a lot
of anger from the left
he now has the cancelled dogs hounding
him for something that he said
about the anthem issue and it was very
provocative extremely controversial i
have to admit
i mean i you know i can't believe
barkley had the gumption to say this
it's pretty shocking listen to this
listen the national anthem mean
different things to different people
i'm glad these guys are all unified but
the people if people don't kneel
they're not a bad person i want to make
that perfectly clear
i'm glad they had unity but if we have a
guy who doesn't want to kneel because
the answer means some to him
he should not be vilified so there you
go if you don't kneel
you're not a bad person that's all he
said this is now provocative and
controversial
now he's right of course but think about
what it says that
this is a notable statement one that
causes people to get angry and outraged
all he's saying is well you're not
necessarily a total dirt bag if you
don't kneel
and the left treats this as a shocking
claim because they demand of course
total and absolute and unthinking
allegiance to their cause and adherence
to their talking points
but think back even a year ago a year or
two a year ago two years ago
um you know you had to defend
the left had to defend people kneeling
and now if there's any defenses it has
to be a defense of people
not kneeling that's how quickly this
issue has
shifted which is one of the advantages
of owning the culture as the left does
number four ellen degeneres who has been
the target of a lot of criticism
recently for
in this case warranted criticism um for
all the countless reports of her being
an abusive sociopath to her staff and
interns
has sent out a letter variety tells us
uh
it's a it's an emotional letter an
emotional apology letter
to her staff she's taking accountability
apologizing
let's let's here's what she says she
says hey everybody it's ellen
on day one of our show i told everyone
in our first meeting that the ellen
degeneres show would be a place of
happiness
no one would ever raise their voice and
everyone would be treated with respect
obviously something changed and i am
disappointed to learn that this has not
been the case
and for that i am sorry anyone who knows
me knows it's the opposite of what i
believe and what i hope for
i could not have the success i've had
without all of your contributions my
name is on the show and everything we do
i take responsibility for alongside
warner brothers
we immediately begin an internal
investigation and we are taking steps
together
to correct the issues as we've grown
exponentially i've not been able to stay
on top of everything and relied on
others to do their jobs as they knew i'd
want them done
clearly some didn't that will now change
and i'm committed to ensuring this does
not happen again
and it goes on from there but that's
basically it that's the gist of it
that's the tone
she she's accused of being a horrible
boss who abuses her staff
and her what's her response to that she
blames her staff
this is a total passing of the buck
to her staff who are the ones who
originally accused her of being a bad
boss
and so she's to prove them wrong she's
blaming them
zero accountability zero responsibility
does not apologize at all for her
behavior
and lays the blame on her staff amazing
although you know in fairness to her you
can kind of see why she
what else is she gonna do i mean the
only other option is to come out and say
yeah you know what i am a total scumbag
i'm awful
everything my whole schtick has been
fake uh i'm not a nice person i'm a
really terrible person
i'm sorry about that now i would i would
respect it if she came out and said that
but you know
it's just when you're when the
accusation is essentially
nothing less than you are at the core of
your soul a scumbag
it's that's going to be a really hard
thing to come out and emit especially
when
your entire brand is being the opposite
of that so if she were to admit it then
her brand goes away and so it would take
moral fortitude and courage and
integrity to come out and admit it but
she's not because again scumbag so
number five finally this isn't really a
headline per se because media matters
complains about us every single day
obviously but
but the latest daily wire clip that
media matters is offended by
is this one from ben's show and
they put the video online leftists are
whining about it as usual
i did have one thing i wanted to say
about it so let's play the clip listen
to this
hey ben i have a star wars question for
you good times i generally agree with
i generally agree with your take on the
sequel trilogy i mean even if you liked
one of those episodes
the trilogy as a whole was just a
failure in my opinion
and i noticed that they had announced
that there's another trilogy scheduled
to begin in 2022 and just your opinion
on
in an ideal world uh where disney was
getting it right
what would you like to see that next
trilogy be about so
i i've said before that i think that
there's uh a great
series to be made on uh darth plagueis i
think that there's a great series we
made on darth bane like uh
the truth is that what makes the star
wars universe interesting uh
is the is the dark side of the force and
so all the focus on the jedi is actually
a lot less interesting than the focus
on the dark side of the force and its
seductiveness um so
you know i guess that the high republic
is supposed to be their sort of prequels
it's based on other jedi which is fine i
mean that's all fine
they haven't really rolled up rolled out
exactly you know how sjw this is going
to be
i know that i know that the disney kind
of imagineers have decided that they're
only going to have female heroes from
now on which is absurd because
star wars is essentially a little boy's
property i mean if you look at like the
percentages of people
who really are huge star wars fans it
breaks down pretty heavily male i would
think
um but i haven't seen what you know i'll
be curious to see what they do
uh to me the only redeeming feature of
the of the sequels in in star wars is
the fact they actually
finally explained why rey was such a
mary sue like that
if they had not then it would have been
incredibly annoying but yeah i'm curious
to see what they're going to do i just
hope that they don't do what they what
they've been pledging to do which is
you know kind of throw in a bunch of sjw
nonsense
how dare he how
i for one am shocked and appalled by ben
shapiro's sexism
appalled now granted of course he's
absolutely right
but still uh yeah star wars is primarily
a boy thing it's
most of it's fans or boys not
exclusively but mostly
that's just true okay you might not like
it it might make your tummy hurt when
someone says it but it's true
it's just a fact um but what i really
want to say here just using ben's point
as a platform to jump off
of and into the abyss um
this push in general to inject female
action heroes into every damn movie and
franchise
is annoying for this for the same reason
and it's really becoming i mean you go
to netflix or wherever
you know every cop show or action film
or whatever it is almost all of them
have female leads now
and yeah it gets a little silly after a
while um
silly because in many cases these are
still genres with mostly male audiences
the left they're the ones that say the
representation is important right
because uh
people when they're watching films they
want to relate to the characters
and sort of imagine themselves as as
those characters
that's the whole reason why we're told
that representation matters in film well
okay
that's also why it's done to turn every
action film with a mostly male audience
into a feminist fever dream
and it's not just the male audience
either i mean i've spoken to many
females who are also
rolling their eyes at the girl power
stick and have had enough of it
yes these are fiction stories most of
these sorts of films
are not exactly hyper realistic to begin
with even so the suspension of disbelief
really gets a hell of a workout when
you're watching a 120 pound
hot chick beat up a bunch of brawny
250-pound dudes
right yeah seeing liam neeson in a movie
like taken
single-handedly kill like 300 albanian
sex traffickers
with his bare hands by himself that's
not exactly true to life okay i mean
you're at no risk of mistaking that for
a documentary
though it would be one hell of a
documentary for sure
but take liam neeson out and replace him
with like
charlize theron and the suspension of
disbelief
has just snapped it's it was already
strained
now it's snapped under the pressure
under the strain
um and and a kind of cool
and tense but also admittedly ridiculous
action scene becomes just a straight up
cartoon
now look i i know there's no way to make
this point
without the media matters headline of
daily wire
host outraged by female action stars or
you know whatever
um no not outraged not outraged
this is not outrage when there's a lot
when you get outraged from me you know
it okay
um no i think it's dumb and silly is
what i'm saying
and a huge percentage of the audience
male and female
agrees that it's dumb and silly um
they just won't say it out loud that's
the difference
okay let's go to our daily cancellation
but before we do um
you got to get the readers pass we've
been telling you about this it's only
three dollars a month
you can start with 99 cents a month if
you know your first month is 99 cents if
you go to dailywire.com
subscribe and get the readers pass if
you want to get the news
and analysis without all the left-wing
spending you got to do that you get
access to all of our exclusive op-eds
you also get um you know you can be a
part of the discussion online with other
daily wire members
you receive push notifications you get
access to our mobile app
the mobile ad free access to to all of
our daily wired news exclusive
exclusive op-eds i can't speak and all
of that you get at dailywire.com
subscribe and join today that was a
great read right there
i am a professional folks okay
let's go to our daily cancellation um
this is a very important subject and i
believe i have addressed it before on
the show
i don't think i've i've taken the time
to issue a cancellation related to it
i don't think if i have then i'm
repeating myself and just deal with it
stop complaining okay
this is my show don't judge me
so i want to show you something this is
a real photo i took it myself
it's difficult to look at i warn you if
you have kids in the room
i would say have them turn away for a
moment uh
not appropriate for them i don't even
know if they're gonna let me show this
without blurring it out it is pretty
graphic
but okay here we go here's the picture
as you can see there those are shopping
carts
in a walmart parking lot left in the
middle of the parking lot
this is what i stumbled across yesterday
there is a cart corral
not but 20 feet away look at the one
closest to the grass
that's five feet from the receptacle
five feet
this is someone who almost to make a
point
had pushed the cart nearly all the way
there and then said no i can't go any
further
i i i can't i've i can't i've gone too
far
my legs will give out it's too much
um and then they just leave it there and
this was a breezy day yesterday
by the way those are not shopping carts
those are torpedoes
all it takes is an errant wind to send
one of those things crashing into
someone's
side panel it has been
the primary goal of my life and my
life's main ambition
to combat these shopping cart ditchers
to expose them
to punish them to shame them
i i truly believe that the entire the
entirety of a person's character can be
assessed based on what they do with
their shopping carts
after they've unloaded their groceries
it may seem like a small thing but it's
precisely because it's a small thing
that it tells you everything you need to
know see if you cannot be bothered for
the sake of your fellow man
to return your shopping cart to walk 20
feet to return it or
five feet to return the car then we know
that the cutoff
the bar for you for what you're willing
to do for the betterment of society
is somewhere below returning a shopping
cart
you see we we know that the bar is below
that
maybe there are some things you're
willing to do for society
and for your fellow man but it's not
anything as as significant as returning
a cart
i'll put it this way if you're trapped
in a burning building
and a shopping cart ditcher walks by
outside are you going to have any
confidence that he's going to run in
and save you no because this is someone
who won't even put his card away
to save your vehicle from getting
scratched you think he's going to risk
his life
no of course he's not which is why if
there was a shopping cart ditcher
trapped in the burning building
i would just leave them to their death
that's a little strong isn't it i'm
coming on a little bit strong all right
let me
i'll pull back just i'll pull back just
a smidge from that
uh here's my point you know
there's there's no excuse uh
so someone said to me yesterday you know
when i was complaining about this
online because this is like i said i'm a
professional this is what i do
someone said we have to make exceptions
for the elderly and disabled and mothers
with children
you know yeah everyone else but make
exceptions for them sorry
no no exceptions first of all if we made
exceptions for old people and women
um then who exactly are you holding
accountable here because that's like 85
percent of a grocery store's clientele
but more to the point if a person is
capable
of getting the cart to begin with
walking around the store with it
doing the 19 mile lap around walmart
going back to their car then they're
capable of going back to the car corral
i don't want to hear the excuse
if you've already done all that it's
it's time to return their cart your cart
you can't suddenly go oh i'm too old i'm
old i can't do it my knees
so i've had i've had an attack of old
suddenly and i just can't anymore
i've already walked 57 miles to get
everything at walmart but but this
that it's the last 10 feet i simply
can't do it can't do it
no we've seen what you're capable of all
right
return the cart gramps no excuse as for
mothers i don't want to hear that excuse
for a minute i've been shopping
with four kids by myself i might not be
a mother i could be a mother for all you
know these days okay if i choose to be a
mother than i am
whether i am or not i return the cart if
i can do it you can do it it's not that
hard
put the kids in let me explain how this
works
here's the process for any any any any
mothers who are
confused about this put the kids in the
car
put the groceries in the car return the
cart
and then come back to your car and drive
away happily ever after
not hard to do oh but i don't want to
leave my precious children in the car
alone
you can't leave them in a car while you
walk 15 feet away
really what do you what's going to
happen when you're when
in that 15 in in the 20 seconds it takes
you to do that what do you think is
going to happen what's the worst case
scenario
what it's it's hot out i can't leave him
in the what do you do when you're at a
gas station do you
do i mean i hope you don't leave the car
running while you pump the gas do you
take all the kids out at the gas station
all right kids get out come stand here
at pump five i can't leave you in the
car alone
come on don't be ridiculous
i actually had a mother tell me once
that she doesn't want to get arrested
for leaving her car's
kids in the car alone while she returns
the car right because there are cops in
the parking lot
with measuring tape and if you if you
walk more than seven feet from your car
to return
a cart uh they're gonna arrest you on
the spot sure i'm sure that's happened
man it's that's happened millions of
times i'm sure it's a really common
occurrence
stop stop with your excuses take
ownership take accountability
i'm not you know there may be some
excuses let me backtrack a little bit
if you get abducted on your way to
return the cart
okay if you get raptured in the in in
the parking lot of a super fresh
while you're returning your cart then
okay i guess god in that case will be
the
shopping cart ditcher and i'll have
words with him about that at a later
date
but or even if you're say batman okay
and
and you're in the parking lot you see
the bat signal
and uh the riddler is about to blow up
city hall and you've got to go and
okay fine i'll allow for that but aside
from those if you are not abducted
raptured dead or batman return your
damned
cart your scoundrels
and rap scallions the lot of you that's
what i say
canceled uh and we will leave it there
that was what was that 10 minutes on
shopping carts okay you know there's
nothing else going on in the world
it's not like there's more important
news happening in the world so i'm going
to carve out some time to talk about
shopping carts because this is an
important issue
and i'll leave you with that for the
weekend to ruminate on and meditate on
talk to you next week godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio was mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more
see you there